[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and these
are the successor to what i called the
best headphones under 200
period so these are the audio technica
ath
so in case you're unfamiliar the m50s
have been among the highest rated pairs
of headphones out there and continually
come down in price actually from north
of 200 bucks all the way down to less
than 120 us dollars on amazon so the big
question now here with the m50x is how
are these different from the m50s and is
that difference worth it i say worth it
because the m50x is actually a little
bit higher price now they come in at 189
bucks brand new still under two hundred
dollars but they definitely cost a
little more so here's the deal they have
the same awesome build quality same
attention to detail the same super
flexible and very portable design ideas
and if you were looking at them from
afar you probably really couldn't even
tell the difference between these and
the m50s except for the little m50x
badge on the side of these headphones
but really the biggest difference here
between the m50x and the m50 is actually
the cabling so you might have noticed by
now that i've been holding the m50x with
no cable attached these guys come out of
the box with no
cables attached to them at all there's a
three and a half millimeter headphone
jack empty on the left hand side to plug
in some audio and in the box they come
with three different cables included and
this may actually be the reason for the
slightly higher price so you get a 1.2
meter straight cable a three meter
straight cable which is actually nine
feet really long and a 1.2 meter coiled
cable which is my personal favorite so
you pick the cable you want to use grab
the end that has the line on it match it
up with the left hand side of the
headphones twist and lock it into place
and now you have audio now because of
this locking mechanism you actually
can't use any third-party headphone
cables you can't use those beats by dry
cables
so you have to use one of the three
provided but what's nice is they're
actually color matching with the
headphones you buy so for the three
different colors of the m50x there's
white
black and this new blue color there's
actually color matching cables and a bag
that i happen to think look really good
with that blue version looks pretty
sweet so that's really what the m50x is
all about outside of that there are
other minor differences you know the top
band of the headphone and the headphone
cups actually feel a bit softer and more
comfortable while keeping that great
noise isolating seal
the top band also feels a little bit
more flexible too so not as tight on
your head so you can have an even more
ridiculously large head
but with the audio quality and that
sonic signature they've taken an if it
ain't broke don't fix it approach the
m50s had an excellent balanced rich
sound with really rich deep lows
balanced mids detailed highs the m50x
have that exact same excellent balanced
rich sound so i love that and for those
asking i've been using the m50s for a
number of years now for traveling
airplanes audio monitoring while
recording
video editing just about everything and
i love them for that and that's a
testament to how great the sound is from
these sub 200 cans you know these m50x
don't need an amp they can sound great
with your phone they're very portable
because they fold just like the m50s and
they're closed back and have a great
noise isolating seal when they're on
their head they're very comfortable it
checks pretty much all the boxes and if
you're gonna spend any sort of serious
money on headphones this is definitely
something to look at for sure so i guess
what we're trying to say here is the
bottom line is these headphones yes are
an amazingly good buy they're a great
idea to purchase
if you have the ath m50s then they might
not be necessarily a huge reason to
upgrade unless you really want that
removable cable there's also a mod i'll
link that right below the like button of
the ath m50s that have a removable cable
mod so it doesn't have the lock and
twist mechanism but you can buy m50s
with a removable cable and you will
still get that slightly lower price so
you might want to check that out i'll
have all the important stuff linked
below so you can get the m50xs the m50s
or the m50s with the removable cable
anyway that's been it thank you guys for
watching hope you enjoyed and i'll talk
to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
you